okay we'll be circle one game just for  fun  just for fun yeah just for fun okay  it's only for fun  and i'm playing the hammer line so i'm  double berserking kind of yeah  he's playing so fast  okay we'll take that one oh he's  berserking as well that's why it's  playing so fast  okay i never noticed the berserk when  there's no sound it's a problem  crushing both on  what's your favorite favorite uh series  oh my favorite series from the 2000s  it's uh the usual suspects yeah that's  my favorite series usually because i  want come on  come on stop doing this  i watched it uh 14 times and when you  watch the movie enough times then it  becomes a series yeah okay so that's why  it's my